[Music]
now
kate in your cupboards this week you
talk about the fact that not so long ago
maybe a few weeks the british government
seemed to be on a roll the vaccine
rollout was going very well
the government seemed to have a clear
strategy as to what it was doing
in terms of fighting covid and in the
last three weeks that's all gone a bit
wrong
and everything's become a little bit
unhinged what has actually happened
well ministers don't want to talk about
it but they were pursuing a strategy of
herd immunity for the autumn
not the way it was previously talked
about when you would just have mass
infection
with no vaccines to protect the
vulnerable but one in which
people were building up antibodies
either through natural infection but
predominantly now
through vaccination a very different
kind of strategy from the one before but
still
one way we reached herd immunity come
september october time
and the delta variant changed that
equation it's far more contagious
and they think that the threshold to
achieve herd immunity is much higher
and so the fact that there seems to be
more vaccine hesitancy among the young
has meant that they've ramped up
rhetoric that does not sound so much
like freedom day
but actually a very new and quite
sinister normal
where we're not going back to our old
ways but we're ushering in
a new era where we will have a tiered
society
where people who are double-jabbed will
have significantly more rights to travel
to
access certain kinds of venues than
people who aren't
jabbed and and i think there are
a lot of issues with this one the fact
that we have not even had a proper
debate in parliament yet
the second that ministers promised in
the winter time
michael gove nadeem zuahi former health
secretary matt hancock that they weren't
even considering something like this
nadim sawahi called it discriminatory
which it would be by nature
and yet now we're in a situation where
the government is announcing it as a
fact
as i say in the cover piece some people
are calling their bluff
they're saying the government does not
actually intend to bring in vaccine
passports
this is a cynical ploy to get more young
people to take up the vaccine
but i think uh you know it's it it
doesn't it almost doesn't matter
whether it's cynical or not although it
certainly will matter if it's not and
they're planning to bring them in and
our lives change in that way
it's a fundamental break uh in in the
trust that we were supposed to have in
our government that
they were leading us through this and
being honest every step in the way
every step of the way now we're at a
point where they're saying to us
i'm sorry but it's it's not going to be
as it once was we're moving into
something that looks a lot more like a
biosecurity state and um
it's not obvious that this is what what
people have signed up for
i want to get back to vaccine parcel in
seconds but but first of all
the delta variant uh has happened we
can't really blame the government
for for the delta variant but perhaps we
can blame the government don't you think
for uh suggesting hope that it was
perhaps
beyond its reach well i mean it is a
communications balance between being you
know hopelessly optimistic or indeed
severely pessimistic and that is a very
challenging line to follow
but i really disagree with the idea that
there's something sinister going on here
um and this has sort of become almost a
libertarian battleground
um but i i think one's got to look at it
rather carefully because
it of course it's people's liberty in a
sense not have a vaccine and to
receive the harms that flow if you get
infected
but the issue here is that vaccination
protects you
from infecting other people and so
that's a quite different argument and in
many countries including the united
states
you basically can't go to school until
you've had a whole set of vaccines
you can't go to harvard if you don't
have an annual flu injection
uh in france and in italy compulsory
vaccinations
in childhood are the the norman have
been for a long time
um there are all sorts of situations
where we legislate behavior
um and you know to some extent it is not
only to protect yourself but others
seat belts uh there are all sorts of
examples
and so it doesn't seem to me to be the
most sort of terrible thing
that actually if you want to go into an
environment
and it is basically indoors
crowded poorly ventilated spaces where
transmission is most likely to come
happen then actually saying well if you
want to do that then you need to have
two vaccines this is not really a
fundamental assault on liberty
i i suppose i i see what you're saying
but i suppose the objection and i don't
think it's just mad libertarians
that think this is that uh there seemed
to be a public debate and the government
seemed to have in fact said it was not
going to go ahead with the
with vaccine passports particularly not
domestic vaccine passports and yet now
it's happening so people feel that
there's a sort of frivolous public
debate
that actually doesn't happen and there's
no parliamentary scrutiny as kate says
and then these things yeah it's clearly
a good thing to have a public debate and
we're having the debate here the point
in the problem
but of course you know as the facts
change people have to change their
plans and you know this is in a sense a
uh
one i don't really like using sort of
warlike metaphors but um the virus
obeys one set of laws which is the laws
of darwinian evolution
and essentially those variants of the
virus that make it able to transmit more
easily
and those behaviors by humans that make
it easier to transmit
more easily are good for the virus and
bad for us
and the challenge is it it's not as
though this is a completely benign
disease if you're young
it's predominantly young people that are
ending up in hospital
and if they've had a pneumonia even if
it doesn't kill them there's a
significant risk that they'll have quite
long-term lung disease
and so the sort of specter of lancovid
which is a whole variety of different
things
is quite significant and it's a much
nastier infection than flu and you don't
really want to have flu either so
it seems to me that you know the
government did not anticipate that they
would have 50 000 cases a day nearly
of a new variant at the time when they
were hoping to
open up the vaccination program has been
an extraordinary success
uh but perhaps not surprisingly as it
reaches younger age groups who feel
themselves more sort of immortal
um there is a bit more hesitancy and
this does two things i mean a it does
actually
if if introduced in this form it it
doesn't incentivize them to do it
can we say that at the end today that's
got to be a good thing to do can we say
the vaccination program has been such a
success certainly the initial rollout
was successful
uh but it seems to be slowing down and
it seems that the vaccine is not as
successful in stopping transmission
as was first anticipated no it was never
i mean frankly the vaccines have been
much more successful than the
the scientific community expected in the
first place to get some i mean
i mean firstly almost 90 of adults have
now had one vaccine dose and they're
heading towards the second dose that's
pretty successful program i mean
much more than in almost every other
country in the world um and secondly
um it's always recognized that there's a
sort of threshold of effectiveness of
vaccines
and what the vaccines are doing is they
are largely protecting they're not
completely
people against the most severe effects
of disease so they are reducing
hospitalizations and they are reducing
death there's no doubt about that
but they are a bit less effective at
introducing mild symptomatic disease
and asymptomatic disease and you know
frankly this is
you know humans against natural biology
it's very difficult to overcome the
forces of nature and vaccines have been
arguably uh alongside clean water
the major public health measures that
have changed human health and survival
over the last
couple of centuries it seems as though
the government has learned from the
example of france
uh in this particular instance because
the french
saw an uptake in vaccination rates among
young people
when they introduced a little as you
would call it nudge as others might say
coercion
uh into into society uh kate do you
think
you know you say that vaccine hesitancy
will increase with coercion but the
example of france suggests that it won't
and that what mark calls an inertia
might go down with a bit more nudging
well i think if you're genuinely vaccine
hesitant i think
you know seeing the way that this
narrative has changed is is probably
going to
shove you towards the skeptic direction
and but as we
as we write in this week's magazine you
know the heavy fist of the state
um can actually be very convincing and
in france we're seeing mass protests but
we've also seen
uptake of the jab amongst young people i
think go up at roughly 75
since he brought in such extreme vaccine
passport rules
um it can work the question is whether
or not as a society we are comfortable
with this kind of not nudge but force
the threat that you will deprive a
person of their liberty
because they're not doing something that
you're claiming is voluntary
you know we also have to remember that
the government is still very insistent
that these vaccines are voluntary but
they're just going to continue to take
away parts of your life
until you do what they want and it's
moving i mean it's
just very quickly it's moving it's
moving very fast i mean about a week ago
maybe two weeks ago the government
publishes guidance for business saying
that they would help them
to develop a system to check people's
vaccination status it was voluntary
with a little note at the bottom saying
if you don't do this
by the way we do reserve the right to
make you less than two weeks later
they're making them and you know this is
what's so incredible
is that they're they're working with the
narrative of choice and yet they're
bringing in this force
and because parliament hasn't been
sitting properly we haven't had the
chance to call this out properly
and say wait a second we have not
actually signed up or agreed to this
it goes against our principles is it
really worth doing this
but i mean the paradox in a way is that
actually the uk
is probably the only country in the
world that's sort of taken off the
breaks
in terms of sexual interaction at a time
when the case numbers are rising
and you know the theory is that when
you've got 50 000 a day and we haven't
really talked about all the pings but i
mean the pings actually reflect the fact
that lots of people are being exposed to
people who've tested positive i mean the
app is actually doing what it's supposed
to do
um although inevitably there are some
false positives and indeed false
negatives amongst that
so that's the paradox which is that
actually this is a government that
doesn't actually like
legislative controls on behavior uh so
the brakes have come off
but it's at a time when the uh covered
car as it were is traveling at
90 miles an hour down a hill that's
that's the challenge and so
you know are they going to be forced to
introduce more
rules depending on what happens with the
numbers and what the modeling does show
is that if you don't if you are cautious
and the guidance is to be cautious then
we're likely to have a smaller peak
than if you simply return to complete
pre-cover behavior
so you know it's a dilemma for the
government in a way which is
they've got a fast accelerating car are
they going to
put some form of rules back on the
environments where the transmission is
likely to be most rampant but lastly
then mark i mean
do you think the problem then is not
obviously that there is some uh
orwellian uh state in the making but
just that the government doesn't have a
clue what it's doing and in a way that's
more sinister
well i mean i just uh i pity the policy
maker it's very very difficult job
they've got at the moment i mean this is
the one of the toughest sets of
decisions
and i mean it's going to be scrutinized
in the finest detail for years to come
but it is genuinely difficult when
you've got a virus that as i say
is not really interested in policy at
all um
and uh it it it's a very very successful
virus this one actually and it will
continue to mutate
so they're having to make decisions on
the hoof and
you know i would rather have policy
makers who change their minds
in the state in the face of uh the facts
changing and i mean the the mantra for
some months has been data not dates um
although
the dates have been pretty dominant in
some of the decision making recently but
but having said that it's i would like
policymakers to respond to evidence
kate it's very easy for journalists like
us uh to criticize what is uh
to criticize the government in what is
an unprecedented crisis
uh should we just show them a little bit
more
charity i think actually a lot of good
faith um has been administered
for this government and you know we've
had debates on spectator tv
defending our editor fraser nelson
defending their decision to delay
uh freedom day by four weeks um you know
we were all shocked by that
you can you can you can try to
sympathize
but when they have these emergency
powers
which control our lives in such an
extreme way
and when we're talking about not getting
rid of all rules but
exchanging the old rules for new rules
that are indefinite and potentially
completely change the relationship
between the individual
and the state sympathy has to go out the
window you have to scrutinize that
because if you don't you end up i think
in a much darker place and
let's hope and that the cynics are right
let's hope that this is all a bluff and
that boris johnson
the once liberal editor of the spectator
he said that he would
tear up an identity card if he were ever
asked to show it and eat it in front of
the official who asked for it
let's hope that deep down in his heart
he comes around and realizes
what a bad idea it would be to carve up
society
based on their health status but as
they're announcing they're going to do
it saying this
is coming in without even having gone to
parliament first
i think our our only job freddy for the
next few weeks is to um
is to uh follow this and be critical
and uh investigate it please subscribe
to
the spectators youtube channel you can
do that by hitting the button at the
bottom of the screen
and also i'd encourage you to hit the
bell which will remind you every time we
produce a new episode
[Music]
you